he keeps talking about quiet quitting
quiet quitting have you heard the phrase
quiet quitting in 2022 American workers
say they are taking a step back from
their jobs which isn't great news for
the economy prosperity of the whole
country and the prosperity for you and
me uh depends on productivity U.S worker
productivity in 2022 had the steepest
drop in the last 74 years here's why
labor productivity is so Central to the
economy and why big drops can be
difficult to recover from
productivity is the amount of output of
goods and services that workers produce
for every hour they put into their jobs
what most economists look at is the
productivity rate which is calculated by
the Bureau of Labor Statistics or BLS
the BLS finds the productivity rate by
dividing the national output by total
labor hours
it might seem simple but actually there
are a lot of factors at play so there's
a lot of inputs and a lot of data that
get revised later on that make it one of
the more complicated statistics to put
together
going back to the equation let's look at
labor hours that includes hours worked
by wage and salary workers the
self-employed and unpaid family workers
the other input National output comes
from the Bureau of economic analysis the
main factor is gross domestic product a
measure of the nation's output of all
goods and services including things like
food gas and health care
but the equation also leaves some things
out when officials measure productivity
they're trying to look at the activity
of the private sector so they'll strip
out things like Farms they'll strip out
things like like non-profits what
they're trying to do is get to the kind
of core of the business sector of the
United States and it's a metric that can
be in important for workers the
productivity of workers is a key
ingredient in creating income whether
it's corporate income in the form of
profits or whether it's individual
income in the term in terms of earnings
and that really is the path to
prosperity and because productivity is
so vital to the economy variations in
the rate can cause repercussions let's
look to this drop here in the 1970s to
find out why a drop like this can
indicate a productivity shock a
productivity shock is when something
good happens or bad happens that changes
the ability of workers uh to produce
whatever it is they produce there were a
lot of things going on in the 1970s like
when OPEC nations implemented an embargo
in 73 pushing upwards prices for oil and
gas and while those costs were going up
so was the amount of workers as a large
influx of women looked for jobs driving
a labor Surplus
and increased competition from Japan and
Germany disrupted trade all of these
factors together led to a productivity
slump
but the Federal Reserve responded in a
way that made the situation worse
so they pumped a lot of money into the
financial system which lowered interest
rates
and those lower interest rates and the
more money instead of getting the
economy to grow at a faster rate just
created inflation and Underneath It All
was that the economy didn't have the
capacity to deliver as many goods and
services as it had been doing before
they made a mistake and it made a bad
inflation problem even worse it took the
FED years to fix that problem
but not all productivity shocks are
negative in the 1970s we had a negative
shock in the 1990s we had a different
kind of productivity shock this time it
was a positive one a tech Revolution
that led to Rising productivity indeed
data on our national economy in recent
months are beginning to support the
notion that productivity growth the
basis for increases in earnings is
beginning to pick up computer chips were
being produced at a faster and faster
rate with higher and higher capacity the
internet became a thing mobile
technology advanced and so worker
productivity grew because of that
technological shock and that led to a
lot of benefits for the whole economy
the high productivity meant businesses
could sell more pay workers more and
increase profits while leaving prices
largely unchanged
but it didn't last due to a stock market
bubble that burst it was the bubble the
bubble has now burst
we've all been waiting for the next
productivity boom and we haven't gotten
it and we were seeing Improvement before
covet hit and then that changed the
whole story the breaking news stay at
home that is the order tonight from four
state Governors as the coronavirus
pandemic spreads the pandemic had
significant effects on worker
productivity manufacturers and Global
Supply chains operated below capacity
ships were stuck at Port and workers
were stuck at home to keep people
spending the FED moved aggressively to
stimulate demand the FED thought that
the work worker productivity would kind
of go back to the way it was before the
pandemic and it didn't and in the
process they over simulated demand so
when you have too much demand and too
little Supply you get inflation and
that's just what we got and
fundamentally at the root of it was
because fed policy makers didn't really
understand how the productivity Tides
were shifting once again underneath
their feet in the first quarter of 2022
productivity fell over seven percent
then in the second quarter it dropped
another 4.6 percent productivity is
ultimately the source of wage growth for
workers uh profit growth for companies
and economic advancements so it's really
Central to the prosperity of the economy
as a whole and the well-being of
millions of Americans economists say
drops in productivity also make it even
harder for the FED to accomplish their
goal of lowering inflation
we're not going to know where we are I
don't think for another year or so at
best the risk is that we get more policy
mistakes before things really do settle
down and Nest productivity continues to
shift with current events it may take
some time to settle down